we won some food podcast welcome to the
word so full podcast with Felipe Esparza
Rosario Torres yeah man and Lisa over
here with the facts what's up everybody
man what a week man Mayweather and 50
cents
going at it get the strap get the strap
we don't even know half of their story
we don't even know what they're talking
about the fight gotten so deep that
they're talking about personal stuff
that they went through that no one else
knows so everybody is confused now so at
first we were all into it you know okay
we know you slept with this chick you
know he said with that chick we know
he's poor we know you spent money on
hookers but then I got to I got you some
crazy dark dark dark dark place for
example you weren't you were watching a
fight no no no bro I got D bro of 50
Cent's came out and said that I'm one of
them
Mayweather friends committed suicide on
snapchat
oh no while talking to Mayweather yeah
what's that true why we don't know they
were deep that's some [ __ ] the team he
don't even know and he said that
Mayweather was playing ti-ti songs no or
Trey Songz okay the whole time that guy
was was talking right but then he really
wait we say he said that when I started
reading everything like people more
people are talking then a real story
came out no bro I said 50 cents said I'm
gonna make up name because I don't know
that I don't know the name of these
people he said man yeah man so I see how
you do your boys your boy Gerald as soon
as he broke up with his lady you wanna
go you wanna go get his lady an
apartment butter a car has Sackler
Center
and then left her but see he's strong
end of the game holds his hoes but Rea
on the other hand he wasn't built that
way so that that fool he um he's
basically said that Mayweather has sex
was it was that lose girlfriend Rhea and
then he found out and then he just shot
her while he was confronting her are you
serious yeah cuz I only see one tweet
this weekend and was just what is the
response by the way whether or not
whatsoever nothing broke they were going
back and forth for a while but man
Mayweather father all that fold up at
the same also go back at the Jamaica
Queens rude like cracked out dude like I
am the captain and he put him next to a
bunch a little rats dude these little
things for him these little Photoshop
things he do it himself
man it's all good I love my little
brother Mayweather 50 cent said you know
what he ain't gonna be able to read this
tweet anyways man get the strap hashtag
strap is like 50 Cent's yeah like you
know get the strap on shoot your ass
real good you know come on are they
really gonna go to the street and beat
it up they were gonna get the strap like
get the belt like because I know that 50
Cent's - what with Mayweather on the to
the ring back in the day yeah they were
boys cuz they wouldn't add it before
though like a year and a half ago two
years and one of them slip with somebody
a little somebody's chick I know it was
a big old beef about who has more money
for but I don't know they took I was
somebody ladies now he took off with
Miss Jackson who was his really yeah
that was May with us but he was beating
her she was on that little
behind-the-scenes thing I would have a
really pretty woman is she was kind of
staying quiet and she said might just
call me miss Jackson or whatever I'm
sorry miss Jackson that's what everybody
called her and then
she's a model I guess where she was but
then she left and then he was rude
Mayweather was saying that he acts he
drama he was just talking [ __ ] about how
little money Nellie must make compared
to him and all the stuff he able to lift
a girl from a gun has yeah he ought to
perform at Magic Mountain that funny but
bagging on his career but it didn't
matter because she was happy he back to
being barefooted you late wasn't along
she was happy was happier with happy of
course but they gonna beat the [ __ ] out
but it was deep cuz then Mayweather put
out a watch that he bought cash uh-huh
18 million dollars and then 50 cents put
up what the state watching his paper
said let's break it down man first of
all the way the fools did this Edward
spends money you know all those other
lawsuits he gots going on all of women
he beat up party he throws the gambling
he goes man they're not his watch he
would have put that back in a jewelry
store he's just begging hard break yeah
man yeah because he was maybe what
Mayweather put up a picture of the watch
and then put up a picture of some report
of 50 Cent's net value has his Worth and
his worth was like 18 million and the
watch was 20 million or something like
that
and who say you shouldn't be argued with
me you should be argued with my watch
you know because supposedly he made most
of his money off that vitaminwater right
and then he sold that away or so he says
yeah yeah but he just filed for
bankruptcy poor thing he didn't doesn't
mean he has no money Swiss bank account
oh yeah man it's awful Kobe Bryant they
get a making a comeback bro are you
serious I'm down for that you know me
I'm where the Kobe's right sorry I'm
searching it's anchors order MacArthur
Park
subi labs of beneth beach bro do you
know dude I'm excited about the Lakers
dog we think she come back he can come
back dog was the last time somebody came
back in the biggest didn't do [ __ ]
well it was magic bro he came back when
everyone went when they had back when he
had Kobe when they had I was check and
he had all these other fool them that
was way before that was before that
before that yeah yeah yeah he was coming
back with a little 1987 moves man but he
came back after aids oh wait yeah yeah
yeah he retired and you know the new
kids came in yeah I don't think Kobe
wasn't in cuz he came in in 96 that was
before and he says like 91 dog 92
shaqtin no no no he can't
magic retired and then he came back late
with big star right but it wasn't
meaning I mean Shaq was with me imagine
he played use it with Kobe or with Shaq
he played with a big no it's not that
because it would have been a big thing
but I don't know dude he came in 96
that's when I came back for a little bit
yeah well yeah because I remember people
were bagging on on comedians I know cuz
he'll play on the basketball that the
past about wrap this around wrap this in
a full wrap but the old school moves
yeah but he came back for a while that
was the Lakers all right
this was Kobe playing with the Wizards
no Jordan was playing with the Wizards
remember came back yeah he came back but
he came back with the Bulls after that
little thing you know everybody needs to
be gone the first time they retire
because the second time they come when
they come back I don't know if any come
back after retirement has been but a lot
of the dudes ain't doing what Kobe does
and when LeBron does they get those
shots to get like stem cells in the
knees and rebuild all that [ __ ] didn't
have all that like you know it's hard to
come back if you're seven feet tall huh
that to man I mean these are wars out
because homeboys only became sad crying
Jordan who did that meme honor that
player dude or was it that chick the
crying Jordan knees who there's there's
a meme like that he has a knees right
there Jordans over there crying don't
somebody had beat up knees I don't know
if it was a player or a role model I
think Cindy Crawford or some [ __ ]
I don't know about it's a lot of
comedians out there they need to need
the crying Jordan
a lot of fools be like front none of
their dog yeah man it's weird like to
complain that a young comedian you know
we're gonna just stay out of the move up
to the next lane you know there's
nothing to complain about I go to a you
know you can really start your comedy
again at the Laugh Factory you just
gotta you know you gotta take one for ya
take your own one you gotta take one for
the team for yourself
do you know go on Wednesday spend the
night let Jimmy see you and then then
you get regulars pass on that you know
what's funny that you're saying that
because the Byron Bauer said that is
even if you're not in the rotations it's
going to do the open mic and do it that
way to get in because a lot of people
don't want to bow their head down
because they've been doing it for 10
years or 12 years or nine years and
there are no I don't want to start over
again and so it's [ __ ] if you want
to be in the mix gotta get in the mixed
up start all over again but you never
started with you if you only performing
Rosemead right and if nobody knows your
material you know they don't really know
who you're the world with huge dog huge
come on fool you know you already had
like mad taste for Mike doing Showtime
then doing K locals and K locals was
[ __ ] hot as [ __ ] dog you had a whole
batch of material then and [ __ ] you know
Last Comic Standing
Showtime now come on young comedian they
get trapped doing their shows in a
certain area like I saw a flyer with
Sebastian latina and there was four
comedians there I never heard of dude oh
yeah never the ones to bring the people
in the Acapulco all-stars he's doing
Bruce's on this day in 96 95 96 season
us when he came back he was thinking
about coming back in the 92 season but
he ended that that attempt right no
Colby
Corie Blount Elden Campbell Cedric
Ceballos vlade divac's
Eddie Jones Frankie King George Lynch
Anthony Miller Anthony peeler Fred
Roberts Derrick strong sedale threat and
Nick Van Exel Van Exel Duke he was with
the Portland and now that was a
rebuilding like squad right there what
they're doing it yeah yeah still that's
what we live now that's what I call them
the Shaq attack and the dudes from Rage
have that one lyric and now I'm slamming
let's check you
how's each other's based his basketball
car you don't have any more I don't know
you had it right there on the rule in
the kitchen dog I do have it or
somewhere that has to be somewhere dog
in the magic right this was all proud as
I got a rookie card dog the magic 92 to
96 shout out to letter 236 oh well
you're in there
95 96 season so he ended his season with
the Lakers just when Orlan era he was
leaving the magic Cobra you should sit
down huh I don't know though like I was
telling you do all that like new like
Bionic [ __ ] you know it's like that fool
this it's a nice boxy but um you know I
mean who knows dogs he has a lot of
skill too you know because I was there
have a couple old heads right there
they're gonna be showing those full some
tricks dude you know who knows though
who knows you know you think that fool
should just take a knee
get off the court drinking the cost of
water yeah man if it knows everything
bro
that's why he watching me live yes I
will be on the Joe Rogan podcast it's
Joe Rogan experience tomorrow tomorrow
what's up fool this weekend I am in
Jacksonville opportunity to a Vietnam
vet now this week I'll be in
Jacksonville Florida at the comedy zone
August 8 August 2 to the 4th August 2nd
through the 4th I'll be a Jacksonville
August 10th I'll be an amaryllis exit at
the globe Center August 11th McAllen
Texas at the McAllen PAC performing arts
arena my kind of text is August 11 at
the Performing Arts arena
Lubbock Texas August 24th at the
Memorial Civic Center Lorado Texas
August 25th and James same saw at sames
Auto Center used to be called something
else they just changed this comedy show
you're gonna oil change
and get your transmission change August
25th seems Auto Senator August 30th
September 2nd
August 30th through September 2nd I'm
gonna be at the Brea improv in
California brain improv that shows that
a sellout man so get your tickets people
I'm telling you you're gonna get these
tickets man if you don't get these
tickets man I'm just gonna be the
funniest guy on lift all right man
funniest guy on uber didn't even check
for drugs on he's these jobs supposedly
did a little bit lakhs on all that any
other job every other job to even to
drive a cab probably to deliver anything
the other a man how much it'll piss on
your thing but left the food driving
many many you know I've been in lyft car
drive lyft drivers to just um they're
working too hard for that first time
that guy is trying too hard brought it
for the car always smelled like ass and
perfume okay okay I picked this up in
the van to take us to the airport but
when we're going to Orlando his car he
had those stinky ass things there were
like five of them in the car those
little canisters you buy at the checkout
oh my god it smells like urinal cakes
you know it smells like that weird wait
you know why though they bought it at
the 99-cent store
sat in a container for two years
live-chat em pick me up bro he was
hiring me well he made a homie you wanna
drive so if we're gonna backseat talk
too much oh yeah man oh man look at
their bio and it stays music whatever is
in your mood I put on my shades bro in
my ski mask talking yeah I'm in acting
so how'd you start your podcast got any
recommendations equipment I remember
that one full
and he would get off your ass so if we
just talk I had this one driver dude man
this one got too comfortable yeah he'll
get like racist but like for 1985 races
like yeah maybe wants to the wall man
[ __ ] my little Buddha head you know what
and you know and I go down to Mexico
right
give me one of those mexican girls you
know but everything it was all
prostitutes like he was telling me how
how he good sometimes he get some
insight you never get some from the
streets
Oh interrupts but it was crazy that we
were talking I know so we're talking
about a scandalous fool you should get
him from the streets oh my god did it
was dude it was most kind I've seen it
and we know another dude that did the
same thing to 40 bucks man so I think
you got cheap here I let you borrow 40
bucks dog just trade rules some mark
today Mark who's Mark bro is he gonna be
able to do a daytime interview can they
come on the podcast how about that one
days off you know everything about East
LA games all right I suppose telling me
that he went to Vegas dude and he will
boil boil high tea sure you know
everyone give me free starving oh I've
never heard straight if I grew up our
first few day don't give me extra soda a
dignitary over here Don asked her
where'd you get that t-shirt that first
day he made it how does that 42 make
teachers daughter big teachers though
you know I find that a little hard to
believe he's cool [ __ ] this [ __ ]
crap Hong Kong and teaches the best mean
flick was in the main strip show at one
time jaimé articles over here are
queries my whole life's a rainbow way
because they have the stage that goes
all the way across my crews I hate fools
they get comfortable they need to build
barriers or a Donald Trump likes to call
them walls I know she's talking about
Emma just like it should be like this
dude pick up the person sit down shut up
you know we already know mean we both
know what we're going already
oh yeah it's it's a you you made it here
you shouldn't be going to so how's your
day going and you hot enough for you
yeah brothers getting hot about you up
close these windows to me on the AC yeah
I hate those holes they don't have it
all crispy cold in there dog I know man
there's so many people who leave it off
until you get in and they'll turn it on
or the wait for you to ask to turn it on
I hate window when the live driver says
there's room for four four passengers
and you get there and the guy was 400
pounds and he sees all the way back
there's no more room for room for two
people that's it San Antonio dude way
like 400 pounds who had a picture of
their lyft driver said my lyft driver is
bigger than yours and this guy was like
in the backseat practically his arm was
spilling over into like the backseat
area it was a huge guy like Moshe or
something somebody like that was posting
I thought it might have been you but I
don't think it was I had to do I had to
do those two pro I had a guy that was
too professional right a bowtie broke
and on the back he had candies dog yeah
all kinds of little girls
bottled water dude he had he has those
sanitizer glue it last year that wasn't
that for dog I don't know Cheetos he had
movies brothers gonna watch a movie
going around the corner dog what was it
a three-hour tour
like the skipper those were those
ratings would come in handy though if
you were able to request somebody based
on the ratings or if you were able to
say no I don't want this guy because
they're only rated two stars like if
you're if what are the ratings for if
not for that like if you do ever check
the ratings of your driver when it says
who your driver is going to be and you
see it's like three stars you are mine
all mine are 4.8 I don't you mean the
people who are gonna pick you up yeah
well sometimes I'm just saying like do
you ever notice what their rating is
yeah they may give those the four and
five stars to the people usually to get
the they get the passengers will get the
drugs like if I think I'm ready for
point nine or four point eight because
he's up somebody there like me like a
driver one person didn't like me guess
what I don't even know who it was
loser but that guy goes that um he goes
on I I saw that um he said I saw I saw
that you were a four point nine so right
away I got you right away and then like
I'm gonna rush to get you I'm gonna
create a u-turn but cuz I'm cuz he
wanted he wanted he went to my affair
over somebody else that was closer oh
yeah
hey dude so what's up with uh in a
goober and lift are different right yeah
because they don't do that little they
don't rate the passengers right lift I
don't think they do but uber does right
mmm what do you guys like better I think
with the car now the car departing apart
bro well the whole reason we switched to
lift was cuz the owner of uber was
supporting the guy that picked us up in
Baton Rouge a little chubby black dude
in that car smelled like Bloods and
everything yeah do that car was how
about the Asian do this blade with it
afterwards he was crazy who from San
Antonio Houston Ray or or Danny
he was an Asian dude it was crazy here's
a class name now who had a cowboy accent
like a redneck accent hilarious you know
y'all cop come on I'll come to your song
I wait for you guys he was cool man here
I go southern accent Oh hilarious yeah
it was Danny bro
he was a character I did another man
character my first live driver or uber
driver that guy didn't charge me because
he recognized me no and no no he
recognized me I mean laughs whoo laughs
so the whole trip
Richie puffs Richie pop oh my god this
is what he sent me doggin if you click
on it it there's a little dog cuz even
like he pulled out a little pin dog I
was little dog fool if you click on yeah
that's his little dog
Richie pops when I first opened it start
shooting stars and stuff it was cool he
picked us up and then he came to the
show afterwards I kick it I was in
Houston what a full shot to Flaco was
doing all right be angry at life time is
ticking on Apple headaches dude you know
but he did the show about doing good man
johnny is over there doing his podcast
with what's-his-name [ __ ] with me
Guerra but pretty much a little doing
the same whack-ass video he's
consistently mm late what I saw you know
I was doing a video of Kiki yeah anafi
that's what I'm saying no I saw a funny
one dog oh this [ __ ] dude he's
driving his car and his [ __ ] his [ __ ]
meet a Mexican grandpa Tata in a
wheelchair next to him bro yeah he's
outside the car in the wheelchair
oh my god how about that one what about
the 88 dog it messed up her hip distance
she's got [ __ ] oh dude she's like
dislocated her hip and everything every
time she told that huh how was that why
she lead I got runned over that brother
brother no white chick you know fake
that one looks real the one with the
brothers supposedly he set it up but he
slipped on that little oil slick dude
who's wearing sandals dog took it to the
Faisel what's up fool chillin doc I
heard you were [ __ ] you're beating up
some chicken McDonald's bro
or if you know we're talking about their
video that came out of the last four
days and McDonald's employees figure out
to a spy-worthy this chore last man
little tongue in huh yeah no dude they
were lucky nuts the other one made look
half asian or something but do they were
lucky nice to the court dude how about
when she tried to hit like be cool and
back up and the chick with the blue
shirt so I'll leave her alone stop and
then she went at her and they she
started beating her but two dogs see
that's ghetto style bro so did my
brother would do a bro so we're gonna
beat up and like everybody's jumping up
he can't he can't get a little hidden in
my name alone but come here man come on
man you're right man you're right little
elbow yeah I got beat up by Samoan chick
dude in high school I've got bit about
mexican chick just like that [ __ ] bro
yeah this is glioma was her name hey bro
she was she knew how to fight huh
oh yeah that big fat chick has fought in
prison though but but you see also how
she used the back at the bottom of her
head yeah she has fought in enclosed
areas before a lot of movement but that
chick I think that chick really
disrespected her and threw something at
her on top of Connor stuff she got she
got wicked on her but she got wait long
she there were you there bro so you know
Curtis he come tell you tell you Pepsi
but you have to do is smooth go for it
all he focused on was the titty that
popped out was sad that take your money
a little baby leg that wasn't a happy
City came out bro and they're like
Stevie everything I'm tired of hiding no
no I was a defeated titty boy what was
she thinking she's [ __ ] fear think
that sugar like I'm sorry she wants a
job or whatever I'm gonna just be
disrespecting people who who haven't got
a [ __ ] raises McDonald started that
goes to show you can't expect anybody
dog is that any Jeannette bad she was
making twenty bucks an hour working
there should I let that [ __ ] sit she
lit that sort of slide one time
it looks like she was wearing a manager
shirt and the other thing I think she's
caught before and told her not to she
looked like there was something personal
there but she called her a fat chick or
whatever and mess up the natter the
chick that was marching through her
through fries and her and a shake at her
hell yeah and then she was trying to hit
her with that thing well remember she
grabs a cheerful and that fat she
grabbed the chair back and saw what
seems that's what she finally backed
down and she's still trying to go over
there like scream and she said that
girl's nipple had the majority of
Facebook but she didn't fall ha ha ha
dude her her her head fell dude you see
how much time I got it got it got it got
smacked on the on the little uh the
booth chairs to go together and it got
smacked on the table dog and on the
other side she got beat up so bad bro
and I felt like she was she there she
was accepted as a friend in 1980 she got
her good she can't be disrespecting
people like that just cuz people work at
McDonald's doesn't mean you can say
stuff to him dude and you know what it
did catch you put the cup back though I
apologize dude I mean [ __ ] she wanted
too much dog she the gave her an inch
and she took a foot she got ass kicked
ass beat Jake was down to low and that's
a little cheap that too dog why she got
hers in dog she got her licks in dude
they both got their licks in because she
was trying to get up on her too dog
grabbing [ __ ] throwing Adam are you
dumb you never did without her house
little round the coast we're gonna blow
laughing dude I bet you she was dog see
I bet you those that if that lady has
kids do you know they don't they don't
trash a dog that's a remember her mama
that's a American ass mom right there
dog you ain't [ __ ] around at that pad
dog she sees nobody don't bring anybody
over after they seen that video I think
they're gonna make a value meal that big
lady bro girl or punch
dude she gets respected now everybody's
gonna kiss the ring dog seriously
imagine dude how many times that girl
had to beat up people in her house oh
yeah dude she probably Punk's her
husband into sex well
couples are tired of [ __ ] married I
don't know man I didn't see a ring but
you know she got it up it was I all do
that funny of me my song that fight was
um it was it was the big girl getting
another punch in a beat right there on
the new DJ Khaled on my phone Aaron the
engineer but uh that little Mimi said oh
those are meme and we know it was the
big girl holding that little girl's
throat she about to hit her again and
they said when your dog has something in
his mouth and you don't know what it is
he trying to get out when your dance
when your dog has something to mouth and
you touching it out with mouths
hilarious she got rocked
you got shows coming up back yes August
7th we're back at the Fox in Riverside
downtown Riverside with mr. Martin
Moreno Latino comedy allstar
no please come out a p.m. tickets
available at the door
August 9th we are doing the EZ speak
comedy again in Echo Park will have
Flaco there if he survives and now you
guys can get a tickets or RSVP at easy
speak comedy at gmail.com also August
14th I'll be in Temecula at the Shawn
shamrock and hit me up on my IG to get
the details on that and also August 21st
I'll be at the dime in Hollywood with
Adam hunter Yemen what's up fool what's
this one on top of my feet I didn't know
Moana had a podcast what so fool welcome
to the Aquaman podcast we'll try to bag
trying to bag it [ __ ] man once you
picture you dog what's up fool nc swamp
life north carolina what up dog big ups
NC Jacksonville we just heard that
improv or the Livity has a new it's
gonna be an improv new club in North
Carolina we're gonna be in Charlotte oh
damn you were in Raleigh last time right
yes Raleigh
now maybe this is gonna be near Raleigh
I can't remember I think it's near
Raleigh like 20 minutes away you know
all those improv czar all in the suburbs
good now we're gonna have a know we have
know how our president jump-starting the
space force yeah man I'm Jeff session
today starting the religion force
religious liberty task force religious
liberty tell what does that entail well
according to them he stole the idea from
has me tell by the way basically it's
it's all religion right well they say
all religions but they've been really
highlighting the Christian you know
religion but they're gonna basically be
handling any issues that have to do with
people's religious liberties being
infringed upon things like like someone
having a poster of across their
workplace maybe but maybe yeah I don't
know that that would have any bearing on
anybody civil liberties or anything like
that but because then you have the
question of civil civil liberties and
and and I know the thing is there is no
attack on the religious right there is
no attack on Christianity and he
actually ended his statement saying we
will say Merry Christmas again
I mean seriously these people think
people aren't allowed to say merry
christmas happy holidays people i say
happy holidays because i worked in
customer service for years in new york
city in LA and there's a lot of people
who are not religious and who don't
celebrate christmas so I tell them to
[ __ ] off I just say happy holidays cuz
that covers everybody doesn't that going
to be unwilling to do with yeah it's
government waste money on it's totally
it's ridiculous and it's like okay these
would handle issues like the Baker's who
didn't want to make a cake for the gay
wedding or more like Supreme Court ruled
in their favor by the way that very yeah
yeah go ahead no I'm just saying that
it's it's these things are already
taking care of themselves you need for a
task force if it's something that
right task force bro it was just like
when homeboy uh what Darrell Gates
started crash it's I did really dude I
mean I could kind understand that but it
is a task force I can't wrap my head
around that I know it's it's really kind
of scary so the whole winner cannot
knock at my door no more yeah do we have
a right not not because they said cuz
even like you sometimes you leave it a
little Roman Catholic sign up there your
mom or whatever or the laughs actually
the little Jewish thing right there on
top of the door the mezuzah a Muslim or
the other two knives bro
every Muslim every man was like cool it
held up nice yeah every Mormon I ever
met every we're not gonna start saying
Merry Christmas
I thought st. Mary cribbing but my
parents are buying me president bro cuz
when I stop saying Merry Christmas oh I
didn't get what I wanted man man man you
know Mary Yuri very happy you say happy
Christmas to get Matthew huh happy
Christmas I think people are afraid of I
think those people don't like the fact
that a lot of people don't say Christmas
but I see it everywhere there is no
shortage of Christmas we've seen Xmas
for a long time Xmas is it X isn't as an
acceptable abbreviation for CH it always
had or actually it's for the word cross
or Chris X has always been an acceptable
shortcut for that it's just a shortcut
I throw the x-men crazy what are you
gonna change culture with that dude come
on man you won't fall for it now oh dude
a lot of people fall for it because a
lot of people's California won't fly
dude or New York or New York you know I
think what these people are basically
saying is California New York aren't the
arbiters of what but American culture is
you know I mean like they're saying
don't don't forget about the rest of us
in the country [ __ ] you and your square
dance fly a long look at law law
textbooks most of the decisions are
either cali or new huge
now they have more influence cuz you
mean and I like the dice man one time
cuz he's bagging on Letterman he's off
Letterman he's your farmer everybody
between LA and New York is your farm
I sure was hilarious people just staring
at that for the Comedy Store what do you
say where those big old clothes here's
the goal of dat times these people
you're in color whatever jeff Sessions
the Diceman I guess by look at a regular
show I can out show he just shows up bro
with glitter I would love him to [ __ ]
put on the 15000 rhinestone Jacky dog
here at home we saw him in Miami know he
was a he had different muscles yeah like
sure that you have like those workout
shirts cut right here loose and big prop
like a 3x big long shorts and boots and
boots like MC Poncho's chillaxing
glasses that's my son remember when Fred
Stoller goes yeah his mom's a bully he
goes to the bakery and shoots to the
front of the line don't you know who I
am
I'm Andrews mother make sure that
everything's fresh till you give me I'll
pay you next week by the way we're
waiting for a guest he's what they have
the gloves on yes he did and guess what
man at the end of the show everyone
stood up and he did he [ __ ] he put up
his collar even though he don't smoke no
more he lit up that [ __ ] Marlboro
light you know he went hickory dickory
dock
Jack and Jill went up the hill with a
buck in a quarter Jill came down with
250 unbelievable
standing ovations hey dude it's awesome
dude it was to do the in his type
because I was anyway
he has them back rubs shoulder rubs are
they right or bro that's when he gets
off to untense them yeah Ryder so like
somebody who yeah I think it's even a
woman though dude yeah cuz they told us
cuz we're gonna chill out with him for a
little bit and he's all
he's uh he's getting rubbed up right now
he's getting a massage yeah Sarge damn
what the [ __ ]
talk to us right away doc you know fixes
little hairs the dice asking bro
[ __ ] yeah he's a [ __ ] dawg dice dice is
complete excitement you know what I
didn't know man
waffle that I didn't know that well I
didn't know suicidal tendencies when
they came out they were I didn't know
that there were so many fights at their
concert that they start banging no they
really get a chance to play they got
banned from the Palladium because they
ripped the chairs off and threw him at
people and shading like just didn't get
a chance to buy from offenders yeah yeah
they're performing there's Ballroom in
that's the old school gun club they were
but they're bad from there then then
they are performing and recreation
centers yeah they no no no no one knows
how am I guess yeah they were dude mad
liability dude right there shows were
crazy cuz there was even a gang so gosu
know the real deal why they were the
first mixed gang we're fuller we're
Pendleton's out yeah that that goes up
that's all then but they all took that
from the street
ham psycho Michael the original drummer
a wall and then rocky George original
guitar player man dude they were they
were hardcore dogs
and they were a suit like by the time
yeah all I wanted is a Pepsi that song
came out they're all like super famous
and kind of mainstream but before that
dude they were the real deal and then
that dude that's my Metallica now
through he oh he was in that band too
and then he did that weird thing for a
while at that funk band called
infectious grooves he did that for a
while too before and then they now
they're back with the suicidal
well uh fools what's up what's happening
brother pleasure to meet you man
oh for sure I fell I was team right here
just talking about suicide Tennessee you
know I seen from back then casual casual
Wednesday talked what Monday Tuesday one
day Monday casual Monday talk today
Monday broad okay so Monday's I don't
get that I don't understand why people's
have a case of the Mondays thank you for
the money
grab the truck a little easier parking
no I think it's people who don't who
aren't like morning people or who aren't
you know who can't function in the
morning those people who say don't talk
to me until I have my coffee
you think city work I'm still a zero
heaven oh yeah you can catch them
sleeping go to Riverside Drive dot don't
want Ali Coney you County I think to be
honestly I think LA County is a little
bit more hardcore than the city relax
I believe I remember going to when I was
on a good one you know with party and I
went to the liquor store to buy more
liquor
I was buying out I was going out danny
bonaduce style bro all I needed was a
longboard yeah but a vodka I think I
bought about a vodka cranberry juice you
know to get the vitamins going and about
cutting a by brillo that's all mine and
that's how a city worker go in there
with big old dump trucks bro big dump
truck that foot but a snicker and
Hennessy bro oh my and going right
outside now for shaking pouring and
saying little bottle his little green
thing a little flat pour it all in there
bro whatever leftover downed it tore up
that hot roll up that's [ __ ] bar to
cover up dragons Chinese grape soda and
it took another whip then in city truck
we're back to work the grape soda is the
most important part of that that story
that's what change is great listener who
drink a lot of deaconate [ __ ] up his
teeth a [ __ ] up his teeth with that
with us they could borrow that grape
soda
cavities huh it was only it was like ten
dude oh yeah he had to get his fix dog
house life is probably hard like when
you smoke when you think we'd hit a ball
huh for the tour little sabers enough
for that ma maybe no no no more I'm
retired man I used to go hard not no
more mr. Allen picky less I thought it
was George Perez burger joint Perez
happy birthday today's also Gina
Rodriguez birthday so there you go you
sure happy birthday to the Atlantic's
loominatee never three years Jane the
Virgin you arrived at Jennifer's yeah
yeah I just came from the writers room
sorry I'm late like literally just we
wrapped up the room jumped in my car
came hauling ass over here there's
another actually there's not a pod kappa
we're writing a new movie we're just
gonna if part of the staff writer knows
saving a podcast we signed his NDA movie
yeah right [ __ ] there's a red carpet
happening this week for a movie that you
were never in and you're listed on the
IMDB suicide road trip and I don't know
what Ian Edwards is invited to the thing
his name is on the IMDB I don't think
this movie ever got made suicide wrote I
don't know it's such a mystery I saw
some they invited you to the premiere
some actresses with who pay a publicist
Wow well at least I'm coming out
somewhere captain what about the red
carpet a good to be wanted
it's good to be wanted Alex said the
guest looks like George bridges older
and normal brother no felonies I'm the
gang accountant say you're an old pit
bull bro dude don't be hitting on pit
bull sexy old pit bull what's up where's
the gas boy your everybody bro
No so you're writing for Jane the Virgin
this is my second season and there's
actually our last season we're closing
it out now yeah yeah it's been great
it's been an awesome right
I started season four and actually
vulture two weeks ago called last season
actually they just named Jane the bridge
isn't the best show on television that's
frigging though it's for a Latino family
that's that's pretty freaking though I
love the show but not season five so
five years yeah yeah staff writer um the
only Latino male writing on that show
there's there's a bunch of Latinas and
some women of color a lot of ladies
which is great because writers rooms in
general are not very diverse and don't
have a lot of women but yeah I'll stick
with it because there are no Latino
showrunner so that's one thing they're
you know what like there is it there
isn't are two working really have two
Latinas where showrunners and that's
Gloria Cal they don't kill it with when
they are at a time on Netflix and Tanya
sriracha with visa on Starz those are
like our only - yeah we need more
valentina Garza which we're trying to
get in rut that's my girl Valentina's on
in the January yeah she's awesome she
used to write for The Simpsons yeah we
want to meet with her by the way trying
to put out we're trying to get in touch
with her Ricky Steamboat and she it's
dark bro you've been at the beach tunnel
right well yeah we're developing us to
come right now and we're trying to meet
Latino show runners yeah it is already
we've met with two white guys we're
meeting with the third and it's just
like these are who they're packing on
you you would attach to to a show last
week loathly
we went all the way to they said yes ABC
said yes to a script okay I said no to
shooting the pilot yeah and then so that
was a holding deal and then Fox also
wanted it
so they pitched it to Fox Fox wanted it
Ava Longoria's production company got
added to the whole mix and so we thought
that was a nice push but then Fox and
Disney's whole merger thing or buyout
just messed everything up and then all
the projects were on hold except for
like two and so it's kind of dead in the
water I'm sorry to hear that
I sold my show last year to to CBS CBS
Studios based on my life as a former
undocumented student oh yeah yeah it was
called illegal at the time I'm still
debating what the title is gonna be but
uh I'm going out in a few weeks to sell
it hopefully gets picked up there so
were you from why should you claim it
like down born and Ecuador South America
came to LA when I was seven years old
long walk that's a no to it Wow you you
are me you and your mom your parents
give me legally that phone that part we
like most undocumented immigrants we
came on tourist visas and just over
stage you know things like 20-some odd
years oh you can say it's overstated
people don't understand that that was
the old-school way of just staying here
it's still coming like um
before like I don't know Willie Barcena
told me that I would that they to cross
the border and the West we got going
which is gonna go to Disneyland for the
day and they let them come in for Lil
and then leave yeah but people had visas
to look who they were coming in to go to
Disneyland with the no stay that that
rhetoric of build the walls so stupid
because then like 70% of all intact
Americans fly first-class you know I'm
saying I know men well a lot of students
are over to the Vito's house I knew
Chinese students who don't we say visas
in new york city owned a word just like
a lot of tech companies i sell like i
can't continue to go to school but i'm
not supposed to stay here but now when
you stay here with your visa overstay
your visa then you're kind of documented
anyhow right Sam I documented well
technically you're not supposed to be
right they have tabs on you anyway like
my parents pay taxes every
year that they were in this country like
they weren't documented and they weren't
allowed to be here but the IRS was like
okay like your money and and my pops was
like you know what I want to do it Dean
as much as by-the-book as I can now and
to show that I love this country and
literally he paid taxes every year and
we pay payroll tax and income tax and
sales tax you know we could were
American and every sense of the word
except you know the fact that we're
undocumented and the American Revolution
was founded on the idea that there's no
taxation without representation and
that's what they're doing to like what
12 million 13 million undocumented
Americans in this country not just taxes
but social security - they can't they
can't claim that Social Security but
they pay into it for the current
generation is that's right they're tired
and what I sold like my TV show is like
a comedy I wrote it as a Latino The
Wonder Years like me just telling my
life story when I was in high school
because this is what happened to me I
was the class president the prom king
the top 10% of my class then I applied
to go to college and I found that I was
on document when I applied to go to
college
your folks never told you I didn't know
damn I did it no and that's so common
now with dreamers who are like I'm a
continue my education and then they get
back like you're not even like my now
bro so what you do don't have a job for
robles be an officer I don't think we
know the whole story dude I think people
go after why not tell you until you were
like 11 or 12 right but you're in
schools I found another hard way moments
where to run wait I don't know there's
about you yeah with my family with my
brother my mom my dad came here first
and then now we came here afterwards my
brother we just met we just my brother
hello girl yeah girls Passport
Nixon that was always a common trick
amongst people to is a to use other
people's passports or cruise in that's
what a mustache is show a little [ __ ]
we drive the cab Akuma Yenta yeah we got
um we got I don't I don't remember that
we were living in Tijuana - I went back
a couple of weeks ago were you living
there because you got sent back though
that guard prepping our hub like the way
station way station what would be like
that guys we met the iguana he said that
most of people who are here they're
trying to get across or they're stuck
here or they're back there they're
returned the north keeper on Cena
okay put us in Aloha he said a lot of
the taste and other customs are very
Sinaloa because Muslim people came in a
beginning response in the Neue Charlie
no did that show that on TJ for a while
in the Crete bill year I thought it's
more for the cheap mariscos man that's
crazy
that's important wave I didn't know
there was 1199 now it's more the first
time I throw 1199 I [ __ ] tore it up
nobody'll pay attention later extra
extra lobster tonight like four of them
does and fireworks tour blew up next
door damn cuz I was gonna ask us with
your story you're already slated to go
to like some IDs I have you League
schools right yeah yeah I waited make
you divert high profile universe and
then so you find that out in the UK what
with the community college route then
totally up to you see a man you you
called it right there like I got the
president know what's doing my life and
ended up at the only place that would
accept me Community College never gave
up the fight because you're fully folks
a little bit more like you know get your
education yeah my dad is actually a
pediatric surgeon in Ecuador and he came
to this country to work at a car wash
and my mom is an anesthesiologist she's
a doctor too and she came to work at
Kmart so they always instilled like go
get an education like you're always
going to school we can't pay for it you
pay for it yourself but you got to go to
school and yeah I just you know like I
was depressed in my knife Kate like I
thought I was like a [ __ ] white kid
that's that's the funny thing
you're living the dream oh man I had
hair back then when I had hair I dyed it
blonde I thought it was Zack Morris
letterman jacket
it was terrible it was terrible little
been jackin everything Opie shorts so I
didn't I don't know how to react to the
news because I never saw an episode of
like Saved by the Bell whereas that gets
deported you know the reason I'm like
what so I went to Community College
that's exactly what I did so what
happened man when you found out why did
you find out eh
I think it was a letter that was sent to
me from the from one of the universities
like you are a perfect candidate can you
send us a real social security number
responsible yeah but you know family
secret you know no but you know it's
funny he's doing good I kind of was but
I asked my mom like all these years
later it's like what did you tell me she
was she straight upset because um we
didn't want you to feel different there
you go we don't want you to feel
different and she said these words I put
it in the [ __ ] joke it's so [ __ ]
relevant she said dreams should not have
borders you can't write corny [ __ ] like
that my your social who was the number I
start with a letter dog it was like one
two three four five six seven go back to
Mexico have somebody work that social
then they'll come back and now you get
your Social Security sent back to Mexico
you double-dip nasty my dear Katya data
deity today deverel but she was she was
born in Arizona lived most of her life
in Mexico but it to somebody went over
here they worked there you go and she it
gets who collected that who collects all
that money now her at the end BAM every
month you go to Mexico yeah picks up
that check she has a theater
the residence there that Jake goes there
yeah she paid the check can't go back to
Mexico but nobody know nothing
yeah you had in the u.s. what did people
do they anything a grip dog a grip and
then cuz you need a social to even work
I mean fire from Jana birth well the
flip side of that coin I was going to
tell you is uh my dad for example this
country didn't invest in his education
they didn't like pay for his schooling
he came at his prime to work his ass off
here so that the other side of that coin
is all the immigrants would come and
this country didn't invest to make them
what they are right give their lives in
their best years of [ __ ] labor and
employment to this country double shifts
over time triple shifts and that's a lot
of thing that gets overshadowed to the
professionals that come here for menial
jobs but they still come out and they
still shine and selling the bony
property yeah I met like lyft and uber
drivers were like I used to be an
engineer Mike Copps at the restaurant I
worked at they were Busboys there were
cops in Mexico that's like why did you
come here like big a full bobbin
intercity it's that much better over I
know I guess he was a cop in it in a
little town with the only have one I
[Laughter]
still movies his shitty towns bro were
that guy's a cop he's catching the bar
dude if we had to be the bar he's got a
badge in the brewery or he's getting
away
dude we're in the south I saw their
little story on the first ever black
police officer sheriff and anyway in the
u.s. in the south and he was in Houston
Texas and he was not allowed to arrest
white people
I've heard that but that's crazy he goes
well you told me you have no authority
you know you know he was not allowed to
arrest white people so what would you do
if if I was asking questions to hear in
my head you know he's gone sir sir well
happens if there's two black guys and
three white guy rubber the bank well
i'ma blow them I'm gonna blow them black
foot away and other why do they have a
good day
he's helping white people arrest black
people that's crazy it sounds a lot like
law enforcement still we're gonna give
you gonna make you the chief but you
cannot arrest the high society that what
happened man named in [ __ ] memory cotton
the [ __ ] here now I'll buy that for a
dollar Robocop
he could arrest he couldn't arrest hisis
rich people bro only poor people they
try to shoot that main dude it's who
gets it today that's like prophecy so
what happened bro after you can eat have
no soul show so what'd you do man uh
Community College Community College I
went to Mount San Antonio College mouths
have I feel like it was pointless though
at that point like can I just say
something about mount sac that I hate so
much when you type it on your on your
text autocorrects to my sac come to my
sac anyway I like to party you said
you're depressed and everything so going
to Community College like that was the
lesser choice for you like doesn't
matter a little bit I'm going a little
bit I'm just going through the motion a
little bit because I don't know how long
my immigrations limbo was gonna last so
that's how actually that's how I got
into entertainment cuz I I just I was
like I don't know how long I'm gonna be
here I don't know imma do I just took
every single class known a man from like
chemistry to anthropology to political
science and I stumbled into like
performing arts and theatre and all this
stuff and that's how I accidentally
started doing it yeah brother and sister
No - well here's the funny thing I am an
anomaly within the Latino community
because I'm an only child which is weird
because we re very very fertile people
but I be lying to doctors allegedly no
my my dad has three and my biological
father has four but I'm my mom's only so
I grew up an only child actually so no
not really I my thing is about building
family in communities there where I go
do you know I mean so like I never felt
like I was alone was cracking yeah oh I
was just saying so how did you get you
so you said you stumbled into performing
arts yeah and that sort of thing how did
you you started acting first right yeah
and it was funny because I didn't want
to do it I thought all of my childhood
friends were gonna beat me up and
they'll be the god that's gay you can do
performing dog but I I did this play
amounts act that I get nominated for
acting to compete at this like five
state acting competition really was four
states and Utah but yeah I guess five
states and and out of like nine hundred
of these students who are competing I
won and then they flew me out to the
Kennedy Center in Washington DC which
was like two blocks from Homeland
Security so I am this undocumented
student performing like to block from
Homeland Security was like the scariest
freakin thing in the world that the the
acting stuff got me into UCLA I went to
UCLA school theater film and television
and it was there that I was that I
realized that there was hardly any roles
for people of color let alone Latinos
and I figured that I had to write myself
into existence and that's when I started
writing what does it you see Lee this is
the most important thing here because a
lot of people want to be in front of the
camera of course and you know we're
developing stuff for him but and you
should this is hilarious develop
anything if you don't have the writers
and producers who are people of color
they won't get it they'll just say no
they just don't get it's the reason why
five Latino sitcoms got a thumbs down
last year and it's it's
the reason why more things don't get on
the air because there aren't people
writing these stories these the non the
people who are heading these these
networks or green lighting projects or
whatever they want good ideas but if
they think the idea is so foreign to
them they think that it's so different
such a different culture or different
thing to write for they don't understand
it they're just gonna say no to it
they're just going to reject it so if
you don't have people in those positions
saying yes or green-lighting things or
writing things it weren't you're not
gonna see more of this stuff on on the
air it doesn't matter how many Latino
actors how many black actors you have
how many Asian actors they have to be in
the writing room they have to be
creating these projects black panther's
doesn't happen just with Michael B
Jordan you know I'm saying or even with
Stan Smith I'm Stan Smith even with
family you know even with him like
that's not getting made it had to have
both of these people coming together and
no disrespect to Stan Smith no actors
the emphasis we should focus on it's a
righty
it's a storytelling absolutely yeah so
when I was at UCLA I decided to - like I
said write myself into existence create
my own opportunities not wait for
someone to give me a frickin role so I
wrote a show with two of my buddies
actually was five of us but three of us
were the stars and it was called [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] or end of you see the way
we opened we opened the Latinos own a
show I remember that were you come on
and I come on [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] no
smell like [ __ ] but I was cuckoo you
get the whole play Rodrigo you were
there the whole play that's the only
dialogue they have is [ __ ] we're back
[ __ ] well not the whole plane we don't
do that for 90 minutes we opening that's
the opening number
so we like me everybody jig went back
and then we steal one another coming
into a big bombs and things like that
right and then what it was it was a show
it was a show about how these yeah one
two or two huh yeah yeah yeah I made a
lot it was it's about how these these
words try to take place of our culture
identity so we decided to tell personal
stories through comedy because you're
not gonna address the serious issue like
racism in America if not through comedy
so we thought this show would only last
like a year two years and literally we
toured for like eight months nine months
out of the year like crazy like crazy
and it wouldn't stop and then eventually
Hollywood came a-callin and we started
developing this is a TV show but it was
my first foray into TV development and
it was the worst experience of my life
you said and I say many of you they
turned into kind of like a social
justice piece so it was a social justice
piece that's I mean when when we first
started we were like how can we actually
say something speak to a new generation
and excite like a theater audience right
so we said let's step away from what
people think of as theater and and bring
in elements of like slam poetry and
stand-up right and and the show it's
truly a traditional three act play but
because it's a comedy people think oh
it's improv these just get up and do
improperly the same improv every night
you know in promoting you and at that
show a live blow for a long time bro
like for a long time I thought you run
better call Saul that's hilarious coming
home me socks you know and that and that
fool is not even Latino I think he's
like British together walk the very car
so that kind of looks like him oh mondo
no he's Latino
no I think you know he's like homeboy
from yeah from a training day like yeah
something like that
I think homeboys Mari but
he's British like Alfred Molina and [ __ ]
I mean the guy in in better cause I mean
it the other guy is Mari yeah did you go
to the opening night for taco shop no
bro I was doing something else I was
with him yeah I was in Chicago too but I
heard all about it and it's good to see
that that movie finally came out it did
its thing I heard it's like really
popular amongst like the urban youth
yeah watching it also men I'm afraid was
a taco shop he plays socks yeah I don't
know how many of these people have
watched taco shop that that's JonBenet
movie but I don't know many fights or oh
I oh I just fell asleep bro most of the
time they were fools fighting brilliant
the sound guy was gonna find out the
director the [ __ ] guy with that I
don't know man to do that those props or
wood or carpenter he was gonna find the
director and a sound guy and then the
[ __ ] guy that the same wood guy or no
he does who those crane so yeah yeah
yeah cameras boom no he's gonna pushed
up I don't know why he does that he puts
like all the cameras together like
though he's grip okay the main grip this
roof on a dog a dog like a stray dog
we had the dogs and I said the whole
time he was there blowing kept it there
on the dog and kept it there turning man
you gotta get rid of that dog
he was not my dog now and then he didn't
like the food blow and he was totally
started a BBQ on set with a dog there so
foolish shot across the street and
killed I remember I mean that wasn't
hilarious but the Ricky back at that
production there right now I we wrote
the movie I put his face and never seen
that guy is from Quebec there you go
yeah he seems for himself it became less
of a rosy and more about the taco shop
manager that I was confused I know man
the whole different movie than I saw get
fired from CBS for that me to stuff
yeah yeah I actually think yeah I know
right I know Rick he's actually a good
guy
they all know whatever whatever went
down and there I think he got the wrong
into that all right first sure for sure
the first thing is he was never an
executive so when they said that they
fired and they said we fire CBS
executive it was like our universe yeah
he wishes he was negative and they only
announced it as an executive when he's
fired that we were lunes to their work
that's crazy and secondly it was
something about like a an appropriate
joke that he made in in a comedy space
you know what I mean
he wasn't mad what a boy Charlie Harvey
was a bad dude it was really jacked up
and then few days ago did you see that
the CBS of Leslie bet yeah yeah the CEO
of CBS the guy was giving hard stirring
a lot of trouble about 10:00 he's still
on still on the air to the dropping the
dropping the stock came down on CBS yeah
they didn't they haven't done anything
the only home boy that got justice as of
late is that a hard way right was Oh
nobody's back we have a couple of
projects coming up well like I said I
have my TV show that I'm gonna be
selling hopefully get on the air and if
I'm it's either gonna be called okay you
got to tell me what's better illegal or
raw for the great
ratha great for the great for TV
audience yeah yeah that that's that's
what everyone's trying to push me to and
and if it gets picked up it'd be the
first undocumented family on television
yeah yeah it's my goal anything I can do
that then you and I have to make a TV
show hell yeah
and oh but if you want Valentino cars
that I get it we're already looking for
a show runners but us here oh yeah the
the show you sure yeah yeah so I'm
launching a digital platform like
through YouTube called annoying cousin
and we have a bunch of shows that we've
been putting up you shares gonna be one
of them LA one for three a young lad
necks like latina finding love in LA
like truly I'm trying to figure out the
way to properly develop content that I
could then turn and sell the television
right so this is gonna be a platform I'm
gonna be developing a bunch of stuff
including you share and I still have all
my other TV projects including a Latino
Atlanta that I wrote that I'm gonna be
probably taking out either this TV
psycho or next TV cycle
um the [ __ ] web retching you got
toured the country right there like
colleges yeah we're like 42 state you do
the NACA
there yeah do you remember that place
did you do that that's where we started
like we didn't knock out and then the
very next day we booked like for an
entire like year it was crazy
that's good macula oh no nothing that
got in [ __ ] bro next to me we ran
out of slips as a given mine - wolf Josh
wolf that's like when you go there when
you go ten yeah but your agent said that
those were like smaller as you ask you
for like lower prices they did you
perform at NACA yeah well the thing was
like knock-knock uh pays nothing they
they pay nothing but his agent was like
well we'll just we're gonna submit you
to the Booker's in a different way so
you'll get more money than these NACA
gigs so it's like what's the point of
this we already paid 150 here that's
crazy
you know our agent told us the same
things but we were like she's got
according groups have them collect a
bunch of groups to you not to get the
money for you you know I mean that so
that's that's what they did for us yeah
it's called a national activity
Association of like college check
National Association of college
activities that's the show where a
comedian like my father myself will
compete with a margarita mixer like a
magician movie a roller coaster next to
me your [ __ ] computer next to me
everybody's getting free rides I'm doing
comedy but you know that's not that's
how a lot of stand-up thanks stay afloat
man they booking up naca shows around
the around the nation yeah I think if
you had been like less known or looking
for less you know it would have been
fine those gigs you can't be asking
these poor colleges for like the $50,000
quote that you asked for fully but you
know I'm saying
over 5,000 yeah well
my friend he did a buncha colleges and I
said man he I believe he bought the
budget I said come here
see that [ __ ] car track ok I see
these eight colleges are gonna get
together pay you $2,000 I see I get to
drive two hours away there's no travel
reimbursement and there's no hotel
usually so you're you're you you you you
just you'd like hardship huh you could
make half of that with less pain and
stress staying at home for $2,000 you
might as well stay at home like come on
you're gonna spend that on travel and
food and going out or whatever
nah that's crazy they get you like that
no no that's great
that's crazy we did it but no no we
didn't accept that kind of quote you're
crazy
what's up for what's your Instagram a
mr. Rafael Augustine you can find me on
the IG or the Twitter I think I'm the
only fellow who's teen on Facebook in
Los Angeles but don't hit me up there
there's like my mom my tias you don't
want me there
Instagram at mr. Rafael Agustin and if
you want to look up any of the projects
besides Jane the Virgin I also run with
arrow dreams almost a Latino Film
Institute and we have the the youth
cinema project which is an educational
program that we do around the state of
California and LA leaf the Los Angeles
Latino traditional Film Festival or
relating to the shadowy what's awful
sure to my new favorite show and I
brought the withdrawal of it red oaks
clause oh no red oaks dirty dancing boy
on her nose is different awful whole
faces there from that No
she took off the glasses when I seen the
eyes it made sense yeah how about you
selling weed rule hey the coke dealer
dog in the Porsche for the fat food
brother yeah the moustache hey what's
the show about
I have no idea the show was on Amazon
only and one of the gals on the show is
we're at a comedy show but your clauses
are [ __ ] bad a show they hold it they
like these chicks who do nails in in
Florida or Georgia and they all driving
a van yeah but it's great because it's
great because they're like ghetto and
they're but they're [ __ ] real and
they act like real the black chick yeah
she ran she plays the Amin lesbian chick
on the show
well she's black she's a black latina
she plays like a dyke bro like a [ __ ]
like a bull she don't let mark bro looks
like Chris Reed so she looks really
magazine and bro from Breaking Bad
really but uh I hope the little weed
dealer hooks up with that chick dog
getting a little heartbroken hot boiler
there dammit they'll be telling the
whole size bro shut up her top was off
we only have like five ten minutes so
let's get back to Rafa yeah it's
represent throw up this up
what's your new social bro what's the
process like if you want to get into
writing or get into the staff writing
business man writing get breaking into
writing is
difficult I've been writing for a long
time besides like theater and like TV
and all these films on spec but
eventually what happened after the end
of you see developing into a TV show I
decided to write my life story which is
this one that just pitched and I send
the script to Sundance and Sundance
selected me to be a Sundance fellow
about like a year ago two years ago and
that's how I everything like broke open
for me because once Sundance like
approves you everyone wants to know the
hell you are then I sold my show and
then I got staffed on Jane but it's
really I mean this business truly it's
like you have to be mentored and you
have to be like an apprentice to
somebody so you got the ranks as a
writer yeah it's so difficult and what
was that grueling experience that you
had after NWC that you said when you
started pitching in or developing your
show yeah yeah like what was that
experien because I was so new to the
game and I was just like so eager to to
to sell a show to get on TV I was I kept
saying yes like I'm like Latinos you
know we're like people pleasers we were
like yeah of course do this homie let's
do this and what happens is in the
process there's the writers as the
producers as the executive producers
does the showrunners there's a studio
this is the network's such a long
process and everyone has notes and
everyone is telling you how to shape it
so what comes out on the other side of
that sausage-making machine was a show
with my name on it that I don't even
recognize yeah so you know how they say
that success has many parents but
failure is an orphan it's like that like
once it came out it was terrible
everyone was like well that was you die
nobody stands with you no one and I was
like oh I get it if I'm gonna if I'm
gonna fail in this industry I want it to
be because of my choice not because of
someone else's choices so I wrote this
new this new show and I'm making it the
way I want to make it and I'm fighting
tooth and nail for my voice and I'm
finding that that's all people want to
hear like just they just truly want to
know okay you know what it is then I
respect that you know I mean so I've
been really fighting for what I want how
I want to tell it the tone the comedy
and the storylines that I want to say
you know are you writing a whole story
arc and a whole season and all that
stuff are you just writing a treatment
at this point to sell it like what's
because some people think if I write a
script that's all I need and whatever
but something but a lot of times a
network doesn't even want to see a full
script yet or you don't want to waste
your time until you're getting paid for
that full script you know
yeah absolutely so stop another TV and
film work differently so film like most
of the time people are writing on spec
and people want to see the work so they
can decide that they buy it or not
what TV that you can't turn any pages
like you have to pitch an idea and a
concept and they decided they want to
continue working with you then they pay
you to write it so I'm at a I'm at the
point where they paid me to write a
script plus I've written out the entire
season I was some fool of Gina Torres
hell yeah Phillipe Esparza chillin
checking out tomorrow on JRE you want to
roll what I'm down for all right what's
so fool afraid right here man thank you
very much thank you for having me bro
sorry I'm late I can literally came out
and if your listeners want to know about
writing or anything hit me up more than
happy to freakin or anything just we
need we need more Latinos and Latinas in
this industry more people of color in
general more than happy to do my own
also messed up asking me people on
internet why I'm not our stuff that you
want me to be on the new show coming up
Maya's yeah dog why aren't you on that
[ __ ] talk to another get into pretty
people right now and the pretty boys are
you know getting the good because people
around me somebody to stab bro be there
need someone else thought of mines I'm
ready the retro dude any
[Laughter]